i will let's speak now to the armed
forces minister james heavy mr [ __ ] good
to see you this morning and of course
plenty to discuss in terms of those
conversations with the u.s president but
i wonder if we might begin just just
with an update on the state of the
evacuation process how many how many we
perhaps expect to get out over the next
24 hours
indeed so in the last 24-hour period
across eight flights the royal air force
have extracted 1821
people from kabul the flow remains good
coming into the ehc at the barron hotel
and we expect to have a further nine
flights over the next 24 hours
um i wonder if you might confirm uh
reports uh kicking around this morning i
think in the times that the evacuation
program has been has been significantly
expanded last week we were hearing four
thousand then six thousand uh to more
than twelve thousand can you confirm
that
well it is certainly the case that uh as
the cases have been made for more people
from afghan civil society to be
evacuated those names have been added um
in reality the focus is on the around
1800 eligible persons so uk passport
holders british nationals and the
remaining people under the arab scheme
which is about 2275
but there are
thousands more who
we would like to get out if there is
time and the capacity
when you say thousands more can you put
a figure on it slightly more specific
than that
the number changes all the time as
people are sort of brought to our
attention and the fact is we will get
out as many as we possibly can
but we've been clear throughout that
there is a hard reality that we won't be
able to get out everybody that we want
to and that's why it's very important
that we start to reassure people in
kabul because i know that people in
afghanistan are acutely aware of what is
being said in our media here in the uk
that the airlift is not the only route
out of afghanistan it is not the only
route to the uk there is a second phase
to this where people will be able to be
resettled in the uk
having been processed uh either at a
handling center in a refugee camp or
at one of our embassies or high
commissions in the region
if we have learned anything about this
government over the past 18 months it is
perhaps that on occasion perhaps more
than occasion you know policy decisions
taken at the very top happen at a
glacial pace there will be people who
will be pleased to hear the expansion of
the numbers under arab but you know the
former chief of defense staff lord
danette was talking about this at the
tail end of july i mean so too this this
conversation to take place with the u.s
president why is that happening tomorrow
why is that not happening today why did
it not happen over the weekend why did
it not happen well last monday when your
boss the defense secretary shed tears
when he conceded back then that not
everyone would be able to come out
because of the time frame on the
operation
well firstly i don't
accept that characterization of decision
making what i've seen over the last
10 days as this
operation pitting has been
going on has been an extraordinary pace
of decision making across government
decisions are being taken in in real
time to answer problems as they arise on
the ground and absolutely everybody here
in whitehall is focused on minimizing
the amount of policy friction
for our people doing a very difficult
job on the ground now
there is a wider question over
whether or not we knew that afghanistan
would fall at the pace that it did
i don't think we did i think our kind of
worst case assumption was that it would
take around six months to reach the
point that we're at right now and i
don't know that a lot earlier than it
became clear a lot earlier than tomorrow
that we would need to perhaps expand the
amount of time that we are on the ground
again i'll ask the question why has the
prime minister not spoken to the
president of the united states about
this beforehand it rather looks like the
u.s president isn't willing to take his
call is that the case
the foreign secretary has spoken to
secretary blinken yesterday the defense
secretary spoke to secretary austin so
we have been having these conversations
with the americans but just to be clear
i i think that everybody needs to
understand that this isn't just a
decision that gets taken in washington
the taliban get a vote on this as well
and i think it's far from certain that
the taliban are going to be willing to
allow the international community to
extend beyond the end of the month and
of course we have they're not willing we
know that they're not willing because
news of this uh lobbying of the us
president emerged we were able to put a
question directly to the taliban in doha
they have said that august the 31st is a
red line their red lines tend to be
written in blood
presumably the point at which we could
have approached the taliban about all of
this was you know a week and a half ago
where they were trying to work out where
the toilets were in the presidential
palace rather than know when they have
complete security control of kabul
i don't recognize that
this conversation could have been
happened happened a week or so ago
because i think nobody knew at that
point the sort of scale of the challenge
in fact
if you look at the number of people that
have been extracted in the last week
6631
that was pretty much the number that was
our target when this operation began so
what's happened in the meantime
is that people have come forward who
have an eligibility under our app
they've been added to the list and
that's why there are still about 2 000
of them to extract which we're working
on very hard to do and then beyond that
there has been an awful lot of people
from civil society that were not in our
plans to be clear they were not in our
plans there wasn't an eligibility they
weren't part of arab but the uk
government is trying to do the right
thing and i don't think we should
apologize for that but we have said we
will try to bring out as many as we can
now that poses a big military challenge
for the generals admirals air marshals
that are planning this mission but i
don't know that it's a bad thing to want
to stretch ourselves to bring out as
many people as possible rather than just
to have stuck with our original number
if no one is suggesting that it is a bad
thing minister what we are suggesting is
that we are we are lobbying the u.s
president to extend beyond august the
31st
after the taliban have said that they
will
they will respond and presumably
violently if that were to be the case i
mean
is our time in afghanistan solely
predicated on the americans if they
leave do we have to leave have we really
not investigated any other options
perhaps under nato for example about
remaining in that country if the us
decides once again to cut and run
well it is certainly the case that
the mission in kabul this week is
fundamentally underpinned by a u.s
presence not just in terms of the number
of troops that they have at the airport
assuring its security but also the role
that the u.s air force are playing in
delivering air traffic control and all
of the other airfield services so there
is a hard reality that there would be no
international airlift without the way
that the united states are are
underpinning it now
whether or not the us can be persuaded
to stay
is a matter for the prime minister
tomorrow in the g7 meeting
after the initial overtures made by both
the foreign secretary and the defense
secretary over the days previous but the
conversation with the taliban will then
follow and the taliban will have a
choice they can either seek to engage
with the international community
and show that they want to be
a
part of the international system they
want to be engaged in international
diplomacy or they can turn around and
say no there's no opportunity for an
extension so but i think everybody has
to be clear that this is not just the
discussion that happens amongst g7
leaders tomorrow it's a discussion that
then happens with the taliban if there's
the opportunity to stay we will but
right now our military planning is
focused on leaving on the 31st because
that's the deadline that is currently
written down uh as when everyone must be
out
it occasionally feels like the prime
minister's perhaps not not as well
informed about what is going on on the
ground as he perhaps should our
correspondent stuart ramsey has produced
some fantastic work in and around the
airport making clear the the dire scenes
that are facing many many thousands of
course the majority of whom will not
make it into the airport itself on
friday the prime minister said that
things at the airport were getting
better where if he'd switched on sky
news he would have been able to see that
they were not they were getting markedly
worse at that point did the prime
minister misspeak was he misinformed or
did he lie
no i also was on television on friday
saying that things were getting better
and they were in so much as
on the 24-hour period before friday we
got a thousand people out which was a
big acceleration on the number of people
that we got out
on any given on any other day that week
and in fact over the weekend we then got
another thousand out on satur on friday
and 1800 out
on
saturday and another 1800 out on sunday
so in that sense that shows that the
flow into the hc at the barren hotel was
improving now the problem was as
everybody saw
in the reporting coming out of kabul
that there was also
incredible proud challenges on saturday
that caused seven people to die
in the crash outside the barren hotel
and i've seen the reporting that
while around the wider airport there
were more people killed further
um that is horrendous our troops are
operating in the most awful
circumstances
what has changed over the weekend is
that the taliban have pushed the outer
corner further away from the baron hotel
which puts a bit more depth into the
process and also if i may now
they've also separated the us and the uk
queues
which makes a big difference to the
crush because a lot of the crush that
was outside the british gate were
actually people trying to access the us
system it's important to know as indeed
your excellent correspondent has done
that once those changes were made
the situation yesterday was much safer
and we're all very relieved about that
how has all of this affected affected
your view of our relationship with the
united states i know from speaking to
them that senior members of the cabinet
are livid
about the decisions taken by president
biden particularly the tone that he
struck in that that that very first
statement why is no one saying this
publicly you yourself served you will
share the view of many people that you
do not leave people behind you do not
cut and run
and that is what the u.s president has
demanded of us
well i mean you're absolutely right that
as an ex-soldier there's a sort of
deeply ingrained psyche that you never
leave a man behind and that's why we're
working every minute that we can to
maximize the number of people that we
that we bring out and there is a reality
to the fact that this airlift has to end
and that's why it's important to say
that there are other
routes to reach the uk in due course but
on the wider issue of uk us
relationships
no one's made any secrets of the fact
that we would have
preferred a more conditions-based
withdrawal that point was made at the
nato summit
but nato agreed collectively the
president is not wrong that we went in
together and we should all come out
together but from where i sit in the
ministry of defense i can tell you that
right now there is a royal navy ship of
haiti working for the united states
facilitating their relief effort after
the earthquake i can tell you that
there's a u.s warship and a u.s marine
corps air detachment under command of
the royal navy in the philippine sea
operating within our carrier strike
group the us and the uk are working
together in sub-saharan africa in the
north atlantic in eastern europe around
the world
the us and the uk remain the closest of
allies of course
when you disagree with your closest
friend it hurts it causes consternation
on both sides of the relationship but
absolutely nobody should think that the
us and the uk have anything but the
deepest and strongest of relationships
and there's stuff going on around the
world that shows that even if right now
in afghanistan there might be a little
bit of disagreement
minister good to have you in the program
this morning uh sorry for keeping you
quiet so long too appreciate it no
problem at all thank you